DAN GALPIN: Android
P Developer Preview 2
is here, providing a
significantly updated
snapshot of what the
next release of Android
is ultimately going to
bring to developers.
Slices allow you to
surface rich templated UI
from your app in places like
Google Search and Assistant.
They can be interactive as
well, with support for actions,
toggles, sliders, and more.
Slices are part
of Jetpack, which
means they are backwards
compatible and fully
updateable, including
new template types.
App actions are closely
related to slices.
Slices essentially provide
a UI for embedded app
functionality, while actions
are a new way for your app
to provide a list of intends
to expose functionality
within Google Assistant, with
possibilities such as watching
a video, reading a book,
hailing a ride, and more.
Android is adding
notification animations
to allow for seamless
transitions from notification
to app.
You don't have to do anything to
take advantage of this feature.
But it will be so
much better if you
make your app start
quickly, particularly when
cold starting.
Typing a reply from within
a notification is great,
but not having to type
at all is even better.
Smart replies allow
you to present
quick choices that can be acted
upon right in the notification.
Text measurement
is expensive, which
is why the new,
pre-computed text
API can offload a large chunk
of this work to a worker thread.
Pre-computed text does
require more memory per glyph.
But in many cases, this trade
off will be well worth it.
Android is also adding
a new magnifier widget
designed for improved
text selection and cursor
manipulation.
By default, classes that
extend TextView automatically
support the magnifier.
But you can use
the magnifier API
to attach it to any custom
view, which opens it up
to a variety of uses.
There are new API to make
your app more accessible.
Accessibility pane titles
allow accessibility services
to determine when specific
sections of the screen
have updated, which
is particularly
helpful for supporting
fragment transitions.
You can specify a title for
a pane, such as the content
area of a fragment,
with the Android colon
accessibilityPaneTitle
attribute,
or change it at runtime with
setAccessibilityPaneTitle.
Similarly, you can
now identify TextViews
as being headers,
which allows TalkBack
to navigate between them.
Previously, the
attribute for Focusable
could be used either to
optimize your app, or keyboard
accessibility, or for
TalkBack accessibility.
We have now added
isScreenReaderFocusable,
so you can make sure that
your app navigates optimally
for both keyboards
and screen readers.
In display cutouts, we've
made a few minor API changes
since the first preview.
Namely, layout in
display cutout mode
always has become short edges
to reflect that P only supports
cutouts on the short edges.
Since the API supports
cutouts on both edges
simultaneously
now, you get a list
of all cutout boundingRects
instead of a single bounds.
We now have a theme
attribute to tell
Android to lay out your
activity in the cutout area.
This attribute will also be
available on some Android O
devices that have cutouts.
So it's a backwards
compatible way
to declare that your app
can utilize the cutout area.
Also, the developer
options now support
emulation of more cutout
types, such as corner
and top-bottom duel cutout.
Android is continuing
to invest to improve
battery life and system health.
App standby buckets
puts running apps
into groups with
different restrictions
based upon usage patterns.
Apps will change
buckets over time.
And apps not in
the active bucket
will have additional
restrictions
around jobs, alarms, network,
and high priority Firebase
Cloud messages.
As a developer, you
can test how your app
operates under each of
four defined buckets
using ADB commands.
Check out the documentation
on app standby buckets
for details.
From our work on
Android Vitals, Android
can detect battery
draining app behaviors.
Within battery
settings, Android will
flag the list of these apps and
let the user apply restrictions
to the app's
background activities.
You can manually apply
background restrictions via ADB
to test how your app
behaves and performs.
You can use activity manager,
isBackgroundRestricted,
to determine at runtime if
background restrictions have
been applied.
Biometric prompt was added
to Developer Preview 2,
replacing the fingerprint
dialog from DP 1.
In addition to
supporting fingerprints,
including in display sensors,
it supports face and iris
authentication, providing
a system-wide consistent
experience.
There is a single use
biometrics permission
that covers all device
supported biometrics.
Fingerprint manager and the
corresponding used fingerprint
permission are deprecated.
So please switch to biometric
prompt as soon as possible.
We've added strongbox as
a new key store backend,
providing API
support for devices
that provide key storage and
tamper resistant hardware
with isolated CPU,
RAM, and flash.
You can set whether
your key should
be protected by a
strongbox security chip
in your keygen parameter spec.
Autofill has added an API
that allows it to work
well inside of recycler view.
getNextAutofillId is
used to manage views
whose content is recycled.
It returns an ID that is
unique in the activity, which
you can associate with
every item in your adapter
as they are initially viewed.
You can then call setAutofillId
on each view as it is re-used.
In the first preview, we
displayed a toast warning
when an app used a
non SDK interface
that we plan to restrict.
But in the second
preview, we are
enforcing these
restrictions, which
means it will get
exceptions thrown or nulls
returned instead of a warning.
If the non SDK interface
is required for your app
to function and there
aren't SDK alternatives,
please file an issue
with us immediately.
Also, StrictMode now
supports a warning
when it detects reflective
usage of APIs that
aren't part of the
public Android SDK,
even if they still
work in the preview.
So you can plan for the future
and eliminate non SDK API use.
The preview includes Vulkan
1.1, a substantial update
to the industry standard
cross-platform graphics
and compute API.
And here are some highlights.
Multi-view is great for VR,
allowing efficient generation
of left and right eye views.
External memory
and YCBCR formats
enable processing of
video and camera images,
while a collection of
additional shader capabilities
improve compatibility,
with shaders
written in HLSL and Open CLC.
Thanks to the support of device
manufacturers and the work
we did in Oreo
with Project Treble
to enable faster
system upgrades,
you can test the
preview on more devices
than ever before, including
devices from manufacturers
such as Xiaomi, Sony, Essential,
Vivo, Oppo, Nokia, and others.
Also, Developer Preview 2 is
available through Android beta
on Pixel and Pixel 2
series devices so consumers
can try it out as well.
As always, your
feedback is critical.
So please let us
know what you think.
The sooner we hear from you,
the more of your feedback
we can integrate.
Look in the video
description for details
on how to report issues, and
enjoy Developer Preview 2.
[MUSIC PLAYING]